wie sicher sind diese schnelltests das
besprechen wir jetzt mit dem virologen
professor doktor fleckenstein uns jetzt
zugeschaltet herzlichen guten abend
jetzt kann bei uns beiden ja zum glück
raus negativ aber wie sicher sind denn
diese schnelltests wie lange ist man den
negativ also diese frage ist in zwei
teile zu gliedern die eine frage ist wie
empfindlich sind die tests und die
zweite frage ist wie spezifisch sind
ziehen
das heißt wie kann es vorkommen dass
einmal ein test positiv erscheint obwohl
keine infektion dahinter ist
ich darf zusammenfassend sagen diese
texte sind sehr gut und sie werden auch
noch immer besser die empfindlichkeit
ist so hoch dass man wahrscheinlich
deutlich mehr als 90 prozent der fälle
erkennt nach angaben der hersteller um
die 97 prozent wenn eine ernsthafte
richtige infektion vorliegt und das ist
eine hohe empfindlichkeit die
allermeisten die infektiös die also
ansteckend sind sind damit auch zu
erfassen mit diesem test und ja zweite
frage ist die der spezifität wie häufig
kommt es vor dass ein test auch mal
negativ verläuft einmal positiv verläuft
obwohl keine infektion dahinter ist und
das ist sehr sehr selten
es gibt hersteller die sagen na ja es
kommt so gut wie nie vor
und es kann auch sein dass vielleicht
auch mal ein anderer test so
größenordnung mäßig in einem prozent
falsch positiv ist aber in solchen
fällen muss man deshalb sagen jeder
positive tests sollte durch pcr
nachgetestet werden
und wenn man das tut dann wird man auch
zu einem sicheren und guten klaren
ergebnis kommen also insgesamt ein
klares ich möchte sagen überzeugt das
votum von mir dass man diese
schnelltests breite anwendet jetzt haben
sie es gerade gesagt danach wenn man
positiv bei diesem schnelltest getestet
wird ein pcr-test damit wird man dann ja
wenn diese auch positiv
dann ist aufgenommen wenn sozusagen bei
den gesundheitsämtern den schnelltest
bisher gibt es da kein zwang sich zu
melden
trotzdem so oder so was für einen effekt
können diese schnelltests für zu hause
die jeder für sich selber machen kann
was für einen fake können diese auf die
pandemie haben
nun ich glaube es ist sehr wertvoll wenn
jeder die möglichkeit hat zu hause zu
testen ob er im augenblick jetzt
unerkannte infiziert ist oder ob er
nicht infiziert ist und es werden sicher
viele fälle seien die auf diese art und
weise identifiziert werden und es werden
sicher viele menschen früher zur
behandlung kommen und aus diesem grunde
halte ich diese tests uneingeschränkt
für günstig und sie sollten breit
angewendet werden und jeder muss in
eigenverantwortung im augenblick handeln
aber auch jeder muss wissen wenn er
positiv zu hause testet er positiv
getestet wird dann muss er auch noch
einen nach testung machen über pcr um
die situation noch absolut sicher zu
gestalten also die schnelltests für zu
hause auf jeden fall sinnvolle das sagt
professor flecken seinen herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren